[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAM RAMANATHAN:
Welcome, everybody.
My name is Ram Ramanathan.
And with me is Rajiv Salimath
from PricewaterhouseCoopers.
What we want to spend
the next hour or so
is talk to you
guys about how you
can use machine learning
to kind of change
common retail processes.
Have you ever wondered how
we can enable customers
to find the most relevant
and the right product
at the right time or
how you can enable
them to search easier than just
doing the data textual query?
Like, that people are
more and more visual,
how do we enable them
to search better?
And that's really what we
wanted to spend some time
over the next hour talking
about how we can apply ML
for common scenarios in retail.
Here is a lovely diagram
of showing how we
do a deep learning neural net.
The rest of the
session is going to be
talking about
convolution neural nets
and spending a lot of
time in deep learning.
And the goal for
it is, of course,
to detect whether an
image is a cat or a dog,
which is great for
my vision scenario,
but what does that
have to do with retail?
The fact that you can find a
cat or a dog is interesting--
I love dogs-- but
does it really help
you guys on a day to day basis?
And that's really
what we want to do
is spend some time thinking
about common ML scenarios
that you can think of in
your customers among your day
to day use and how
you can apply that.
We think of three
key scenarios where
machine learning comes to play.
One is enabling your
customers or your users
to find the right product
at the right time, right?
How do we take people,
moving them away
from just regular
textual searches
to thinking about finding
products more visually?
The other aspect
is how do we help
them recommend the right product
at the right time, right?
If you really think
about this, one
of the things that we deal
with more and more is choice.
And the thing is we can help
customers is, how do you
give them the right product
at the right time based
on their prior use behavior?
And the third piece
is, once you have
released a product
out into the wild,
how is this product doing?
What are people
talking about it?
What else are they referring
to when they use this product?
So you guys can get a
better feeling of sentiment,
understanding what they
do with the product,
and get a better answer that
can then drive your life
cycle from a product development
perspective, marketing
perspective, and multiple
downstream activities.
So I'm going to talk about
a couple, three scenarios.
So let's talk about why
finding their favorite product.
How do we do that today?
Today, most retail
stores, we normally
think about their
online web presence.
It's normal, you
have a textual box.
They do a product search query.
And people normally kind of
gravitate to search first.
Part of it is because
of their behavior
that they do every day when
they open up a Chrome browser
and they search in the tab.
And they kind of got
indoctrinated to search first.
So in those kind of scenarios,
how was your search experience?
And so far, searches
have been mostly textual.
But one of the things that
we've seen more and more
is people are moving more
and more to images and video
to kind of communicate, right?
Whether it's messaging
applications,
whether it's people pinning
their favorite images
on Pinterest or on their
favorite social app.
Or even if you think about
scanning through blogs,
get inspiration to what
they want to purchase.
Once they do get
the inspiration,
what do they do with that?
They can't really
find their product
at their favorite
retailer anymore,
because it's an
image, most probably.
So how do we enable
those scenarios?
How do you enable your consumers
to discover products easier?
That's one aspect.
The second piece
is how do we think
about recommending the right
product to the right customer?
I think one of the use cases
when we think about Google
and recommendation is we
have over a billion hours
of video content watched
every day on YouTube.
And you may say, OK, what's
that got a recommendation?
The reason people watch
so much video on YouTube
is because they see this Related
Video tab on the lower right
corner.
Based on your user behavior,
based on your product metadata,
we then serve up
appropriate videos that's
relevant for your context.
Not just the clickbait, meaning
that if you watch a cat video,
show more cat videos, but
really focus on what's
relevant for that end user.
And thinking about time
to view and saying,
is this is a video you
really want to look at?
That's a case of a
content perspective.
But you can then
translate that to products
on a day-to-day basis.
Just because somebody
bought something last year
does not mean they're
going to buy something
this year, because maybe
externalities like seasonality.
There may be social events.
Because one of their favorite
teams won their sports event,
that may drive behavior.
There may be other
things that are
more internal factors that drive
recommendations, [INAUDIBLE]
out of stock, et cetera.
And how do you think
about taking all of that
to drive the right product
recommendation for end
customer?
And the third piece, as I talked
about, is sentiment, right?
Really now that you release a
product, it's out in the wild,
people are doing all kinds of
craziness with your product.
But then what's going
on with the product?
Do people actually
like it, right?
I mean, it's funny enough.
I am a frequent customer of both
Google Shopping and at Amazon.
And I spend lot of time
reading those reviews.
Those reviews clearly
influence what I purchase.
And so thinking about for
USA manufacturer or retailer,
you really need
to understand what
are people saying about this
product out in the wild.
And you really want to
understand, what else are they
talking when they talk
about this product?
What are the other entities?
Who's the most
perceived substitute
in the customer's mind?
What else would they
normally talk about
from a comparative
perspective when
they talk about your product?
How can we help you
understand that?
And that's normally,
all that data
is not necessarily
inside your organization.
A lot of data is outside your
organization in social media.
How do you then harness all
that data to get insights
into your recommendation?
So that's really
what we're going
to spend the rest of the
time about these three
scenarios-- finding products,
talking about recommendations,
talking about
sentiments, and how do we
start driving scenarios.
Here is a quick view of
all the different services
that we provide on
Google Cloud Platform
to really think about that.
And what I want to spend
some time with today--
how do we bring these
services together
for one or two scenarios?
From a machine
learning perspective,
in general, there are two key
ways that we provide access
to machine learning.
One is as a platform play.
So that's really where
we have clearly--
we're going to be talking
more about TensorFlow
tomorrow, where we
think about TensorFlow
as the number one open source
machine learning platform.
But any of you can build your
own cloud models on your data,
run it anywhere.
And then when you
want, when you're
ready to run it at scale
in a managed environment,
you can bring it to our cloud.
And we have cloud
machine learning
engine that helps you really
drive your machine learning
models, both from a training
perspective or prediction
perspective.
And that's really targeted at
data scientists and folks who
want to really manage the
machine learning life cycle
from end-to-end perspective.
At the other end is really what
we talk about machine learning
APIs.
So these are APIs
that's really focused
around using Google models,
using Google infrastructure,
and providing you targeted
solutions for scenarios.
For example, our own
language to help you
do things like finding
named entities,
meaning entities
in a block of text,
or finding things
like sentiment.
Whether it's an image--
we released Vision
API last year.
So how do you find
common entities?
And in the case of video,
we just announced yesterday.
So really, that's where
we're using Google models
to try to get insight
into unstructured data.
And we also have other
APIs like Jobs API, where
we're focused on very
targeted vertical use cases,
like thinking about
job placement.
And that's really kind of the
portfolio of machine learning
products that we have
today from Google.
Platform, on one hand,
based on TensorFlow
with Cloud ML Engine and
a set of ready-to-use APIs
on the ML API side.
And the goal for
this talk is talking
about how can we use
some of this technology
to drive, to go
back to those three
scenarios we talked about?
How do you find your
products easier?
How do you help drive
recommendations?
And the third aspect
is, how do you help
customers understand sentiment?
So let's first focus
on the first one.
How do you help find
the right product?
So there are a couple of things.
And the scenario that
I'm going to focus on
is really around searches.
Search by image.
As you can imagine, there
are lots of other pieces
that you can do from a
find the right product.
There are things on search
engine optimization.
There are things about how you
can tune your existing search
index and tuning better
using [INAUDIBLE] search.
But in my mind, those
are technologies
that have already been in
the market for a few years.
It's kind of a
well-understood process
of how you think about
search engine optimization.
How do you drive searches
across your metadata today?
People have solutions today.
So what I want to spend
some time thinking about is,
how do we think about
finding the right product?
And that there are
a couple of things
you can go around the thing.
One is, when a user
of your website
sends an image as part
of the search box,
how can I get metadata
on that image?
What is that image about?
So I can drive a search process.
The other aspect is
thinking about logos.
Is there any product
branding information
that I can take to
drive certain aspects?
And then how do I
think about fraud.
If I'm a marketplace and
different people are posting,
sellers and buyers, sellers
are posting products
that they think they're
ready to sell, how do you
know, as a marketplace owner,
that this is the right product
or not?
Is somebody just doing
a phishing exercise,
where they're taking
some random stock image,
posting it on the marketplace?
Is this a valid image?
And so we're just going to talk
to a couple of ML techniques
that enable that scenario.
The first piece
is image metadata.
This is something we
released last year.
It really works in more
generalized scenarios.
So that the information
you get back
from what we used to call a
Vision API is more generic.
I would say, a higher level
of categorization information.
It's not very targeted,
specific information.
But it can give you things
like it's a leather handbag
and give you the
color of the handbag.
And that can give you
metadata to then drive
on subsequent search.
So for example, one
of our customers,
they may be enabling a search
by image feature in their app.
They want to start
driving things
like, hey, I want to search
for, say, brown canvas bag.
So we'll give the color.
We'll give you the
term it's a bag.
And potentially, if
it's a canvas bag.
And then you can then
drive a search index
based on that
within the metadata
they collected already.
Another piece we
talked about is,
how do we think about
using the web for fraud
and topical entities?
What that is is we just
released our new feature
called Web Detection.
So that's really
the functionality
under Google Image Search.
So what that gives you is if an
image exists on the web, right?
So that's important point.
If an image exists on the web.
And our web crawler,
as you can imagine,
we crawl through billions
of pages on a daily basis.
We index a lot of these images.
We can then find metadata about
that image and feed that back.
So when you post an image
to us, we can then tell you,
this metadata on
this image based
on lots of different pages that
we scan, is this means A, B, C.
Does it make sense?
And we can also tell you
if a similar image exists
somewhere else on the web.
So that's another
aspect that we provide.
So really, the
scenario we think about
is if it's topical entities,
where it's now here,
for example, you want to find
a product with a very famous
logo, we can pick
up that character,
like a Marvel character or
a character from a BBC show
that's very popular in the web.
We most probably would pick up
that character from an image.
And the other aspect is also is
for fraudulent scenarios, where
if you're a marketplace,
you want to see,
are these people posting
fraudulent images or stock
images on the marketplace?
All right, so we'll all
do it out of the box.
And I'll show you
some examples of that.
But be careful about this.
Because we use the
web metadata, we
can get a lot of
false positives too.
So for an example of this,
this is clearly a Stormtrooper
image, but we also give you
a metadata called pregnancy.
And you're like, why
did you get that?
So if you click on
this link, it actually
goes to a Pinterest page.
And somebody there
has used this image
to drive a baby shower, right?
And so that's [INAUDIBLE].
So very clearly, it's a
very popular pinned page.
And so a lot of pages
are linked to it.
And that drives our ranking.
And it clearly was on this
image of a Stormtrooper helmet.
It's now linked to pregnancy.
So you just need
to think through.
I just want to caution
you, this is not a antidote
to all problems.
It works well for
many scenarios,
but also doesn't work
well for some scenarios.
So that's a piece that I
wanted to leave you guys with.
So let's kind of walk through
how you want to do that.
Can you switch to a demo?
Perfect.
So let's start off with this.
I'm a big Star Wars junkie.
So in case you guys see a
lot of things [INAUDIBLE].
So it's not that
Disney is endorsing
me or anything like this.
It's just that I like
"Star Wars" stuff
So here's an example
where, for example, we
get all this information
based on this image.
It's LEGO.
It's Star Wars.
It's Lego Star Wars.
So it's information
about the product.
And if you go back
to the prior image
where we talked about
the [INAUDIBLE] bag.
So let me go back
to that scenario.
So here's another example
where, in this case, it's a mug.
Again, I'm a huge
Star Wars junkie.
So in case you're wondering
why all my products are all
at some relation
to Star Wars, it's
just because "Rogue One"
is an awesome movie.
I think I'm not wired
on the internet,
because I think you guys--
[INAUDIBLE]
So let's go back and
start this again.
So for example, in the
image that I just showed you
earlier in the thing,
so in this case,
it brings up a leather bag.
And here's the metadata
that we give you.
And this is the other
additional metadata
that you get from the web.
And so you can imagine how you
can start using this metadata
to drive the scenarios.
Again, I just
wanted to reiterate,
for the web metadata, it really
depends if a similar image
exists on the web.
So if it's an object that's not
present on the external web,
you most probably will not
get any metadata on it.
I talked a lot about products.
But there are also other cases
where people are thinking
about furniture shopping.
People are thinking
about other scenarios.
And here's a couple
of examples of that.
So in this case, I
basically pinned up,
grabbed a bunch of images
from-- for example,
you have a for, potentially,
a furniture store,
people are coming
and loading images.
They want to find similar stuff.
And you can imagine
where you get metadata
on those pieces or the box.
We give you additional
metadata that you can now
use to drive potential
additional searches downstream.
I'll just do one more image.
And then I'll go back
to the "Rogue One."
And the key aspect
is here, for example,
we recognize it's "Rogue
One," Star Wars, Jyn Erso,
et cetera, based on this cup.
And then the other
piece that we also
give you is information-- where
else does this image exist?
So you can imagine, we give
you this additional information
of all the stores where
this image shows up at.
So that's another
essential piece.
We think about a marketplace.
People have uploaded
a bunch of images.
You guys want to do
a quick fraud check
to see what if these
images are stock images
or they come from
a valid place, you
can very easily run those
images through the API
and see if these are
valid images or not
and then use the subsequent
metadata to drive searches.
Back to slide.
So let's move on to
the next use case.
We're talking about
recommendation.
So in the case of
recommendation,
there's a lot of
different scenarios
that we want to talk about.
Really, you can
think about it drives
a lot of different scenarios all
the way from thinking about how
to view the right
content in YouTube
to thinking about how you can
write appropriate cross-sell
or upsell for the customer.
But as I mentioned, there's
a lot of different factors
that drive into the
recommendation aspect.
So you really want
to think about,
what's the history
of the user behavior?
What has a user been
doing on your site?
Or what purchases have they done
with your store prior to that?
What's the current
product metadata?
That's really where,
if you can imagine,
if your product is more
of a physical device,
your product is more of a soft
device, whether it's a video
or it's a piece of
content, you really
want to get that metadata, so
you can drive things downstream
around recommendation models.
And Rajiv's going to talk
a little bit about some
of the models that enable that.
We provide you a rich
platform to enable that.
And so right now, what
we use is TensorFlow.
So [INAUDIBLE] really when you
think about machine learning,
there is a pipeline for that.
There's a pipeline for really
thinking about training,
how you think about training
this model, where you take
your data, the data
gets the data in GCS,
in Google Cloud Storage.
You feed it through
a data flow pipeline
to process the data to get the
right features that you want.
Then you get a
TensorFlow model that you
have gone through training,
that you look at the model
parameters, tweak
it appropriately,
and then the model goes
into production, which then
drives downstream processes.
So this is really where
TensorFlow and things
like cloud ML Engine comes
into play to really drive this
into a model scenario.
But then you can
imagine, the pipeline
doesn't just sit with
machine learning.
The pipeline is end to end.
The pipeline goes
all the way from how
you think about your logs
data, your clickstream
behavior coming in
from-- whether it's
cloud Pub/Sub, whether it's
metadata flowing through things
like Cloud Storage.
And the end result
is really thinking
about all your analysts who
have to do things around hey,
help me understand
my prior history,
my sales behavior,
my purchase history.
And thinking about how to
then figure out all the BI
and data warehousing
stuff that's
been going on for 10, 15 years.
All those things does not go
away with machine learning.
You can imagine, you need that
to drive machine learning.
If you don't have that, go
back and fix your BI and data
warehouses.
Because without data,
there is no ML, right?
So the dirty secret
of machine learning
is 90% of the work is getting
your data into your data
warehouse, cleansed,
processed, so you
can drive downstream
machine learning processes.
So we shouldn't
forget that piece.
Think of it as a tip
of the spear, right?
It's a shiny part, but
there's a lot of work
that happens to get that data
to the model for training.
So this kind of
scenario kind of talks
about the end-to-end
pipeline, not just from how
do we feed data, whether think
about clickstream behavior,
these are lots of events that
goes across all your servers,
feeding through a cloud Pub/Sub
pipeline that's integrated
with data flow that
does your processing,
then dumps your
data into BigQuery
where your analyst
most probably will
run a bunch of
queries and analysis
on that with your favorite BI
tool, whether that's Tableau.
And then once you've kind of
done your data processing,
what they call the
data janitorial work,
where you figured out what's
the right data, what's
the right features, you then
do subsequent processing,
feed that into a format that's
compatible with TensorFlow,
create your cloud
machine learning model,
create a TensorFlow
model, and then
you do some appropriate
level of evaluation,
then put it in production,
most probably not directly
in production.
It will have to do things
like an A/B test process.
We figure out if
this the right model.
Am I getting the results I
want in actual production
before you roll it out, right?
There's a lot of
processes that happen
before user behavior data
goes to an actual ML model.
What I want to hand
it off to Rajiv
is to talk about
how someone actually
did this in production.
And Rajiv is going to
walk through a use case
where he's helped the customer
walk through the scenario end
to end.
RAJIV SALIMATH: Thanks, Ram.
I'm juggling lots of devices.
And I hope all of them work
OK with Wi-Fi and the screen
resolution.
Great.
So I do machine
learning stuff at PwC.
And we do a lot
of the dirty work
that Ram was talking
about, taking data,
taking historic data.
And across our clients, we
see some clients have a lot
of data, but they have security
issues about what can be used,
what cannot be used.
Some clients don't have data.
And some clients just don't know
what type of data they have.
And we take that data
and we figure out how
to put it in the right context.
And we've built several
training models on TensorFlow.
And I'll talk about
one of them, which
is for a company called Sky,
which is a large television
package provider in Mexico.
It's kind of like the
Verizon or AT&T of Mexico.
So the challenge here
is that they literally
have door-to-door
salesmen who go and try
to sell you different
television packages.
And over the years, they've
got lots of sales data
in terms of what television
package was sold to which area,
but they don't have any data
in knowing which type of people
are interested in sports
packages, which type of people
are interested in HBO, who
wants to watch reality TV,
or anything like that.
So what we created
for them is we
built simple tablet
applications,
retail kiosks for them.
So users can interact with
these kiosks in a fun way
and they can just pick
a few movies or TV
shows that they like.
And based on that, the
machine learning code figures
out what type of
television package
and what kind of
hardware, along with that,
that person would
be best suited for.
This is a problem where you
have to try and figure out
what a user wants
with very little data.
In other sessions,
we've spoken about what
to do with a lot of data.
And we built this
on a cloud platform.
Essentially, what we
have is the kiosk screen.
And all the app code is
driven on App Engine.
And we basically
have the input data
coming when a user
selects different TV shows
that he or she
likes, and that goes
into a single-layered
neural network
that we've built and
deployed on TensorFlow.
And I'll show you some screens
and graphs from that as well.
And based on that,
the TensorFlow
figures out what products should
be recommended for that person.
Essentially, the
math challenge here
is, how do you do good
filtering for a user
without having a lot of
data about that user?
There's a lot of different
types of filtering you can do.
Essentially, they
all have fancy names.
But basically, it
comes down to, do
you want to filter stuff
based on what this user has
done in the past or based
on if I like to watch HBO,
somebody else
likes to watch HBO,
and that somebody
else also likes
to watch Comedy
Central, then what's
the likelihood I would like to
watch Comedy Central as well?
And there's different types of
filtering techniques like that.
We've picked a collaborative
filtering technique here.
What it basically means is
if you have all your users
on one axis and you've all
your shows or TV packages
on the other axis,
you have some data
for users for some
of the packages
and you have holes in places.
And so the whole
mathematical challenge
is, how do you fill the holes?
How do you know that if I've
picked A, B, and C, then
what's the likelihood I'd
be interested in D as well?
And the reason we use
TensorFlow for this
is our initial training data
had something like 20,000 users.
And on the other axis, we
had some data for these users
on about 300 different
types of TV channels.
So essentially, it was
like a 20,000 by 300 matrix
that we were executing.
But that pretty soon
exploded into having
over two million users and
something like 20,000 data
points.
And so that becomes a very
hard computational problem.
And that's where you can easily
tweak your models in TensorFlow
to scale with the amount
of data that you get.
So I'll try to show you
some of these things.
Do you which one to
plug into the tablet?
Can I have the tablet
screen, please?
There you go.
It's going to be a
little psychedelic,
because for some reason,
I can't get it to work
in the other resolution.
But think of this as your
afternoon neck exercise.
But you could also drop
by at the PwC booth.
And it works in a less
psychedelic way there.
So let's tap on this.
We call this the
TV Show Gobbler.
So it first has a little
image recognition thing.
It recognizes me.
But I always make this joke that
all machine learning, the goal
is to detect Indian
names properly.
And it still detects
Rajiv as Ratchet.
But we'll go with that for now.
Let's play.
So imagine this as a kiosk.
And it shows you a
bunch of TV shows.
And you select a bunch
of things that you like.
And it's going to try to figure
out what your interests are
based on this.
Definitely, "Halt and
Catch Fire," "Westworld."
And if you see the
bottom tab, it already
detected-- from a very
little amount of data,
it detected what I like.
Obviously, the more number
of things that I pick--
got to pick "The Wire"--
the more number of
things that you pick,
the more it learns about you.
And so let's see what it
kind of figured out about me.
So it figures out a
bunch of interest tags,
a bunch of things based
on facial recognition.
It tries to estimate my age.
And then it looks at, you know,
I like the show "Halt and Catch
Fire."
How many other
people have liked it?
In that age demographic,
how many people like it?
And it executes that
tensor computation.
And I'll show you that.
And based on that, it
selects these different--
the ones which are white are
not things that are for me.
And the ones that are in
color are what the algorithm
thinks I'd be interested in.
And I'm so happy it
didn't pick reality TV
in front of all of you.
So let's see what it
recommends based on that.
So based on this
now, our customer Sky
can figure out what type
of bundle of TV package
they can sell to me.
And these bundles have
different channels.
And they're at a certain price.
They have a certain amount
of hardware with it.
And if I select one
of these bundles.
And then you can have other
related products to it.
And this also has
image recognition.
But if I place a
product in front of it,
it'll detect the product.
It's trying to do it right
now, but I don't have a product
to place in front of it.
But any product, whether it's
a bar code that it could have
or a product, you put a
Google Home or a Daydreamer
or something in front
it, it'll pick it up
It'll find the right price.
It'll allow you to
add it to your queue,
contact the sales rep, all
kinds of things like that.
So if you come over to the
PwC kiosk at some point,
we'll show you all these things
in a better screen resolution.
If I can have the
laptop again, please.
Can I have that link
for the TensorBoard?
Thanks a lot.
RAM RAMANATHAN: Could
we move to the demo box?
RAJIV SALIMATH: Great.
So I'm not sure how many of
you know a lot about this
and are going to grill me
about that, how many of you
don't know much at
all about TensorFlow.
So I'll briefly go
over some things.
So essentially, TensorFlow is
a computation engine, right?
And you give it
some model and it's
going to execute it for you.
And how you design that
model, which in this case,
happens to be a
single-layer neural network.
And when you feed it, so you see
this thing called Softmax here.
So that's kind of the
function that we use.
And that decides kind of
the bias and the weight.
So if you think about all
the users on one axis and all
the interests on another axis,
let's say, hypothetically,
it's a 20,000-by-200
matrix, right?
And out of that,
that's my input tensor.
And that has to give me
an output that tells me
for each of these 20,000 users,
which one of the 10 television
packages they can sell to me.
So the 20,000-by-200 input
training tensor should give me
an output of 20,000
by 10, essentially.
And to do that, essentially,
you have to do some kind of--
if you were to do it without
something like TensorFlow,
you'd sit and compute different
permutations and combinations
of the weights that you have
to put into this and the bias
that you have to put into this.
So the beauty of
TensorFlow is that it
allows you to define
a function and play
with the bias and the
weight in rapid time
till you can get your
input model to a level
where it looks like you're
getting the right outputs
from the training set.
So when you do that,
when you have that model,
and then if you look
at the distribution,
essentially, over time, it
has to kind of converge,
so you know that the
bias that you've given
or the weight that you're put
into your weighted algorithm,
it's kind of coming to
a sort of a convergence,
so you know how good or
bad your training model is.
And I'll show you
one last thing maybe.
So if you're doing
anything with TensorFlow
and you've always got somebody
yelling at you, saying,
how do I know how
good or bad this is?
How do I know how
accurate this is?
And you kind of have to look
at a loss curve over time
to kind of say,
hey, you know, it
has to go down a
little bit over time,
even if it doesn't
go down this much.
If it's not going down and that
last curve is not reducing,
then the variance
is too high and you
have to go back and kind of
tweak your model some more.
So I just wanted to show
you a couple screens.
And TensorFlow
makes it really easy
to do those things
on TensorBoard
and execute the functions
on TensorFlow instead
of having to kind
of go through lots
of permutations of iterations
for those input functions.
So that's what we did with
one of our clients, Sky.
And I'll give it back to Ram.
RAM RAMANATHAN: So that was a
quick aspect of [INAUDIBLE].
Going back to the story we
were trying to talk about.
Help you help customers
find the right product.
Then second aspect is
from your perspective,
recommend the right and relevant
product at the right time.
And then the third
piece that we want
to talk about is a
little bit about,
how do we go back to
understanding product
reception, right?
How do we think about what's
going on in the field?
How is this product
getting received?
What are customers
talking about it?
How do we understand
product reviews, et cetera?
And that's really
what I wanted to spend
some time to address
that third scenario
and talk a little bit about
how we can just really
focus on natural language
[? understanding. ?]
A lot of the
scenarios, we're going
to talk about that aspect.
There's a lot of
other pieces that
goes into kind of getting
product reception.
You can imagine aspects where
you think about reference
for your product.
There are other
pieces, like, if you
start thinking
about social media,
and you think about the images
that flow through social media.
And you want to start
associating, hey,
how's my product logo
perceived in social media?
What are people doing
normally with my product?
That's another aspect
that we can think about,
logo detection and
image processing
to enable those scenarios.
But the other piece, which is, I
think, a lot more, I would say,
fundamental is product
reviews, right?
You get this product
reviews galore.
There are things that people are
talking about on social media.
What are people saying
about my product?
There are product reviews
coming from magazines,
from publishers.
Find my product.
Tell me what's going on.
Tell me what's relevant
for my product.
What else are they
talking about?
And the other aspects
is when you think about,
when you look at
a review, things
that you want to understand
in the review is,
what are the entities they're
covering in my review, right?
For example, when they
talk about my product,
what other product are
they talking about?
What other competitor
are they talking about?
What else are they
associating my product with?
That's really the thing
I just talked about.
For example, suggest phones.
For example, if I'm
selling a new model phone,
what else do people
normally think
of when I talk about my phone?
And the third part is,
what's the sentiment?
Was it positive or negative?
So you can then
drive those pieces.
Further downstream
pieces, you can imagine,
are things like, hey, what are
the most positive [INAUDIBLE]
features, what are the most
negative features, et cetera,
to drive product reception?
There are lots of other
pieces that come into this,
you can imagine,
product telemetry.
If you're electronic
products, a key
aspect to drive future
product planning.
But in this piece
is what I'm going
to be talking about
really around,
how can we use
language understanding
to see what the external
world is talking about you?
So if you switch
back to the demo.
So the data I'm going to
focus on is the Nexus 6P.
So basically, I'm going to
start off with Nexus 6P and say,
here is a product review.
I picked a site.
It's on Trusted Reviews.
And they focus a little aspects
of how this phone is received.
And what I'm going to
do with that is actually
use that product review in the
context of our Natural Language
API.
So Natural Language
API offers things
like named entity recognition.
It recognizes the most relevant
entities in a block of text.
So it finds things like
around organization.
It finds things like people.
It finds things like consumer
goods out of the box.
And most common
[? nouns ?] primarily where
these entities are normally
linked to a URL on Wikipedia.
So you find if it's an
entity that's in Wikipedia,
most probably will pick it up
from a Natural Language API.
So let me go ahead and
grab this piece of text.
I hate doing a live
demo sometimes.
Because I actually
had copied it,
but then mechanical problems.
So let's go to analyze it.
So one of the
things that I wanted
to show that is the
first thing it picks up
is if you look at this
concept called salience,
so first thing is, it's
scanned this article.
And it's picked up that
this article is really
about the Nexus 6P, right?
That's the first thing you
really want to understand.
Hey, you're going
to get a lot of text
coming into your organization.
What is this article about?
So that's the first
thing it finds out about.
The other thing you
want to think about
is things that's really focused.
One of the key value points
that Google really want to land
was premium, right?
That's really, we
focus on Nexus 6P
as a premium consumer
mobile device.
And again, the good thing is
this article actually brought
that up into [INAUDIBLE] flow.
The other aspects we wanted
to talk about is, are there
are pieces around design,
salience, other pieces that--
are there other consumer
goods that's normally
referred to with the Nexus 6P?
In this case, for example,
we pick up the fact
that people also talk
about Samsung Galaxy
S7 in the same article.
So you can imagine those are
substitutes from a customer
perspective.
We think about, how do we bring
those two products together?
Let me do another example.
In this case, I
brought up the Pixel C.
So I'm going to go ahead and
copy that piece of text here.
So in this piece,
again, the key pieces
that you want to
think about is, so
what do we want to understand?
We want to understand what
is this article about?
Second thing we
want to understand
is, what other
organizations normally
is referred to when we
talk about this product?
We bring up aspects,
like Samsung.
We think about other
products that goes with that.
And then the other
thing that I want
to also start thinking about
is, is this about a tablet?
We figure out it's a
consumer good out of the box.
You can imagine,
we start picking up
salient entities out of this.
So the piece that I
also want to then drive
is, the next piece I
want to talk about is,
how do we think about the
sentiment of this article?
So I'm going to bring up an
article about Google Home.
Sorry.
I know watching me copy text is
not the most fun thing to do.
So a couple of things.
In this case, what we've done is
look at the sentiment analysis
using our Natural Language API.
So basically,
Natural Language API,
when you take a block of text,
you run it through ML API,
you get two kinds
of scores on that.
You get a document sentiment.
And the two pieces you
get is whether the score
from minus 1 to plus 1.
Minus 1 being negative.
Plus one being positive.
And then a magnitude of how
positive that article was.
So in this case, you would
think this article is actually
moderately pretty positive.
And then it gives you things
like document sentiment.
It kind of walks you
through how the article
itself kind of flows.
So as you guys start
thinking about taking
this block of text, if you think
about product reviews coming
in, you want to start
scanning all these articles,
start figuring out which
article refers to my product.
And then the second
thing you want
to start thinking about
is, are these articles
positive or negative
on my product?
And the third part that
I'm not covering today
is, you can also
imagine that you
want to start looking at
which features are positive
and which features are negative.
And that's some part
we're not going to cover.
So in the end, what
can you do with that?
So you can imagine things like
relationship graph, right?
So we've done is we
basically ran every Wikipedia
article through our
named entity recognition.
And we basically started
mapping a relationship graph
based on which entities are
common together in an article.
So this line
basically shows there
are a lot of articles where, for
example, Nexus 6P and Motorola
show up in the same article.
It's a ticker line and
it's a shorter line.
And the case, for example,
Nexus 6P and Sony, [INAUDIBLE]
a few articles with the right
level things, a much longer
line and it's a thinner line.
So it's kind of a very crude
form of a relationship graph.
So you can now thinking about,
how do all these products fit
together?
What's the relationship
with the product?
You can even imagine,
you can start
adding sentiment to that line.
Say that this sentiment
is, normally, you
got strong sentiments, positive
sentiments based on reviews.
So you can get a
better feel as you
start looking from a
product perspective,
from the sales perspective,
how the relationships drive
certain behavior.
Does it make sense?
And of course, that's great
from a product perspective.
But what I want to
end with is something
that's more important,
something for-- who
is Tywin Lannister related
to in "Game of Thrones?"
Because I'm a big
"Game of Thrones" fan.
So you can imagine, you
can do something similar
for "Game of Thrones" thing.
And you can see right now the
Tywin Lannister is connected
to Tyrion Lannister,
even though it should be
a much stronger relationship.
How many of you are
"Game of Thrones" fans?
Not that many.
So this joke just went
right over your head.
So coming back.
Slides, please.
So what we went
through right now
is, again, circling back
to what we talked about.
We talked about the
three key scenarios
that machine
learning can enable.
One is, how do we find
the right product, right?
How do we provide a more
intelligent search process
within retail sites?
Thinking about image metadata.
Primarily, in this case,
is search by image.
The second piece we talked
about is recommendation.
And Rajiv walked
through a scenario
about how do you enable
sales folks to recommend
the right product to customers?
And the third part,
we just talked about,
is understanding feedback
based on products
and understand how
are people talking
about your product, what
else are they talking about,
so you can start building
relationship grabs
with appropriate
level of sentiment.
So that's really what I wanted
to cover in this session.
I wanted to leave time
for more questions for you
guys for the next
10 minutes or so.
There are lots of other
[? share ?] sessions
that cover going deep more
into machine learning.
Some of them may
already be done.
So when we did the slide, you
can imagine, a lot of sessions
happened before.
I think there's one tomorrow
on the data life cycle, which
I highly recommend.
Also, and there's
things are on how
to use TensorFlow with
a lot of the things
that Rajiv talked about.
There's a good
session around, how
you do TensorFlow on
cloud ML without a PhD?
I think those videos
are up on YouTube.
So those are sessions
that, if you guys are
really more interested
in TensorFlow,
I would highly recommend.
Some of the aspects
around ML APIs.
We have a session that
covers, basically,
how we do all the
different ML side APIs.
Kind of does a walk-through
that Sara Robinson did earlier
today.
Those videos are
also up on YouTube.
So with that, Rajiv, I'd like
to invite Rajiv up and open
the door to questions.